Tony it's lovely to see you here at
collector mania today how you enjoying
it so far it's extraordinary this is my
first time in Milton Keynes we have done
several shows in London I did Birmingham
twice and a couple things in London
proper women Leigh Stadium once but
there's always good to come and see a
collective group of fans and people who
appreciate the work that all of these
guests do and absolutely come up and
tell you you know and that means all the
things in the world if somebody actually
takes the time to appreciate what we do
as artists what more do you want and
that's we have dialogue too many artists
in the past like left us without anybody
really telling them to their face how
much the particular things have impacted
your career what are the highlights for
you being born love that moment came out
kicking and screaming no you know I was
raised by a single mom who instilled in
me a sense of pride I didn't even know
we were poor until I was around 13 with
some house he was a house a house
cleaner domestic and somehow we always
had a plate full of food
I had a big growth spurt when I was in
high school she supported that and she
more importantly she always told me I
could be whatever I wanted to be and
every summer she would put me in a
different program from the Boy Scouts to
geology classes to science fairs every
summer I had a different activity that
was structured and
one did I'm she put me in a public
speaking form and once that happened I
discovered the power to voice and it
coincided with my lack aesthetic ability
my lack of an athletic ability I was
like totally uncoordinated because of
the growth spurt one day in English she
just said you wanted to try reading this
and she gave me a copy of Shakespeare's
Tempest and I went home and I read it
was like watch one of those 3d books you
open it it just springs to life it was
such vivid writing and such powerfully
stimulated imaginative wanderings I said
Wow
immediately ran out and dissin for the
drama club didn't get that role but they
said I could help backstage I was a
curtain puller but I was a dedicated
curtain player and I just love to bring
them sometimes I put me cooking down
while people were still performing I
said give it up get it up get it up and
uh next production I got and then that
was it I was hooked
performing in front of my peers I was a
shy kid and I was a stutterer just
communicating and finding that joy that
passion I think that applies to
everybody whether it's acting or
directing writing whatever painting
sculptor II got to find that passion the
thing that inspires you you know you can
do well in that you're not afraid of
trying
do you remember think then after the
programs that she put you in when you
got your first role well she was proud
of me even when I was doing plays in
high school she was the first person in
the Senate of front row you know I went
to university dropped out she wasn't too
happy with that but she gave me about
two years get my life together before
have a lot of police officers in my
family and during that time they used to
come for Thanksgiving and sips of one of
you why you want to be an actor well
just join the police force
that's because I don't I don't
I don't I don't want to kill people and
finally I went back to university got my
masters in theatre got my Equity card
which is the Union for the opticals in
the States and she saw that and then oh
she became to me when I was doing my
master's program coming to I was writing
and stuff finally I got platoon which
was my first movie I remember calling
her it was a Monday was raining on Fifth
Avenue in New York got a movie I was
dancing in the street like Gene Kelly I
got a movie she says great great great
where you have to go I see the
Philippines
she said she hung up the phone took me
three weeks to convince her that was
gonna be safe did it and then of course
I became her smiling baby boy again when
you look back over your career which are
the films that kind of stand out for you
that you've enjoyed the most as an
experience I enjoy them all even the bad
ones I mean they're all you never know
going in whether it's gonna be good or
not no fortunately more than 75% of them
have been memorable it's been a few
clunkers but even that you learn from
tune stands out because it was my first
film I had an incredible cast half of us
it was our first foray into film you
know people like Johnny Depp Willem
Dafoe keep it David for his Whitacre coy
Glover you know we were just excited to
be making this thing by this magical
madman Oliver Stone who was dedicated
and fearless and taught us that and then
you know candy man came along Star Trek
came along I always go back to theater
though I just finished the play the
Denver Theatre Center by Markus gardling
is the next great playwright directed by
che you lose out to selective Victory
Garden
forty-eight salad straight standing
ovations that cannot compete with film
because it's impro it goes away it's
it's in the moment it's right there and
then it's gone film lasts forever even
the bad ones you can't get rid of it
most of it I'm happy that is there Oh a
recent standout was when I did I'm a
video gamer so when it called me to do
call of duty black ops 2 made me sign a
contract saying I could not talk about
it to family friends anybody strangers
under the suffrage of death and for some
four months I couldn't talk about what
everybody knew was going to be the
biggest single solid release in
videogame history and finally there was
and but and seeing yourself digitized is
an awesome frightening Twilight Zone
like experience because now my emotions
are in some a member of your bank
somewhere and they can I can go away and
they can do what they want I mean as a
fan as well as you said your video game
what was it like kind of first or being
asked to be in it and then seeing the
final product it was the first campaign
of that actually finished I was
determined to finish because I wanted to
see every single you know it's
interesting you know we I worked on it
for four months actually and the
campaign doesn't last that long so I
have ten-year-old kids going yeah I love
you know that so how long it took you to
finish about three hours children have
the innate ability to just not think
like adults where we think about
possibilities it just barrel through
right so and also doing video gaming you
have these points of dot points of light
all over your body which is basically a
Navy SEAL suit no pockets and a big
tennis ball on your head
and like they told me each one of the
dots cost thirty five bucks something
that there's like 365 on you in a room
surrounded by 262 cameras
so everything movement you
was choreographed and there's no props
there's only you and a few other actors
and all that other stuff is later on
after it's a little backwards but try to
make it believable
and you mentioned Candyman of course at
earlier and you know still a film that
people love so much incredible film why
do you think after all those years
20-plus years it still has a place in
people's hearts I think it's a movie
whether it's any it's got a story it's
got a beginning a middle an end and it
opens the most incredible lines in [ __ ]
history what's blood for if not for
shedding it's also a gothic love story
and I think that resonates you know
people talk about their being frightened
and scared or but just something about
it there's something real about it that
makes you frightened you know and also
people deep down like to be afeard but
not in the jokey way it is mostly
prevalent I mean Candyman is not about
jokes and we have a great combination
Clive Barker Burnet roles are directed
Tony Richmond all from all from England
you know Philip Glass the chemistry
between myself and Virginia Madsen it
was just just a series of things that
connect a little bit about your
experience behind the scenes of filming
Candyman well at that time I was doing a
lot I did a lot of active research you
know I was into creating story books and
Virginia and I had ballroom dancing
lessons and horseback riding and fencing
to try to capture that data thing that
we then brought into the work yeah I was
also I just done nine Living Dead to
remake so I had my first lead role and
my son was born and that was important
just attention to detail yeah we didn't
people kept telling me all this rolls
gonna change a life
so you still bearish at all you might
not live it down and said nah that's not
true
they underestimate me how did you find
things changed after that
you didn't hit immediately I mean the
movie was a hit but then I didn't hit me
too like two years after it my daughter
and I was shopping Christmas shopping
people get running up to this day I
still I pinch myself because I've never
never got everything oh I am I'm all
that I'm just happy to be doing that and
people came and she finally she was like
four she says dropped a little shopping
bag that candy man that's my dad
and that resonated so much with me
because it made keep keeping it real
yeah this is my job I have an attractive
job but at the end of the day you have
to be a man first or a person first you
have to love your family you love your
friends and cherish the things that are
really important now you mentioned also
that people have been talking to you
about transformers today as well and
what is it about that world you think
that attracts people as childhood
memories you know it's based on a toy
that people have played and the whole
thing of the magical thing I study magic
the whole thing of something being one
thing it didn't change it into something
else
and then also the cooking and the pots
and pans the prime monists that
everybody likes the world being
threatened and destroyed in a petition
sometimes you come dangerously close to
pushing the envelope and I hope that
never happens in all of our lifetimes
politics aside you just have to keep
playful and what was your experience of
working on that behind the scenes
Michael Bay who had hired me for The
Rock two years previously he had always
told me we'd work together again and he
kept his word and he called me one day
and said I would you like to destroy the
universe
the rest is history it's you know I do a
lot of voice or vocal acting these days
too
you know somebody asked me well how is
that different and it's for you have to
isolate the joy and find the joy without
having your face and your and your
physical presence it's about like I'm
developing a thing about a cat I rescue
cats I have a cat named cat daddy Neko
and you know he speaks like you know
boots on the ground tells up tells a
book
mochi won't you tails up in boots on the
ground that kind of stuff so you find
you know just let it go and find it be a
kid the interesting thing about all my
roles I was a single kid so in my
backyard I played aliens I played
Cowboys I played robots played people in
spaceships and it's all come true and my
pirates and my adult life and that's the
greatest gift of all it keeps one young
doesn't it my pleasure
don't forget sushi girl out there folks
at first when I produced starring Mark
Hamill you know on half away myself is a
gangster film google it you'll find out
about it and it's available have a
Twitter account just started using it
Tony Todd 54 you can keep up with all
the upcoming stuff and connect with fans
and friends internationally definitely
thanks so much Tony thank you